on behalf of the prop masters who woke
them one of the greatest science fiction
films of all time whoops
Lucas film executive Pablo Hidalgo
recently took to Twitter to share an
image which perhaps constitutes
considering Star Wars as popularity
one of the biggest goofs in the history
of cinema will put it this way if you
never knew that the Skywalker Klan
originated in the Big Apple
you're in for a surprise we know what
you're thinking I don't follow but bear
with us in her doll ghost tweets the
executive began by noting its belief
that the Star Wars flicks offer
something new to the audience upon every
viewing an assessment that probably has
more to do with the series diligent
attention to detail than it does
boneheaded errors but the Faunus latest
viewing of Empire Hidalgo had once more
detailed the palette in like a vicious
Whomper defending its territory the
etchings on the bottom of Luke
Skywalker's lightsaber remember the
iconic scene in which the budding Jedi
uses the force to summon his weapon and
frame self from his I see upside down
imprisonment it's pretty cool fantasy
stuff right but it turns out this moment
has much more grounded in reality than
you might expect
Hidalgo Rhodes I've noted this before
but every time I watch a Star Wars movie
there's something new to notice
especially if I'm fortunate to catch it
on the big screen this latest discovery
that new york is visible on the bottom
of Luke's lightsaber in Empire it
certainly seems like a heck of an
oversight on the part of the props
departments so how did it happen in
standard theatrical screenings the
marking would have been barely legible
to the audience but the Empire Strikes
Back was a hotly anticipated sequels of
a single most pop culture dominating
visual effects driven blockbuster the
world had ever seen as a result it's
enjoyed a profitable run in theaters in
the high-definition 17 millimeter
formats which makes the markings much
more visible still it seems no one
noticed or made note of the goop until
2019 how could it be the out of
thousands of fans are viewing the scene
in the highest resolution available not
one of them notice a Luke's lightsaber
was apparently manufactured in New York
for that matter we'll do you want better
Empire has been available on blu-ray for
years a release which bows pristine
resolution and assault tons of copies
probably literally and still no one
notice the error many Star Wars
aficionados consider the Empire Strikes
Back to be the undisputed high point of
the entire series there are probably
some fans have watched this movie more
times on a sum total of every movie you
have ever seen so the fact that this
plates a mistake has escaped the
attention of one of the most dedicated
and rabid fan bases on the planet for
almost four decades is quite simply
mind-boggling
hidalgo engaged in a lively exchange
with fans on the wake of his post many
of whom were quick to point out that
while the error was indeed visible
it wasn't exactly legible the doll girl
responded on the big screen it can be
seen though of course it took about 40
years for me to notice it all go also
pointed fans who may be interested in a
deep dive into the star wars series
props to water websites parts of SW com
that features a nifty compendium of all
the common everyday objects which were
used to bring the series well to life in
the tweeting question
Hidalgo referred to many of Star Wars
props as being quote eco friendly from
looking at the collection of recycled
gun parts tape and old TV equipment it
seems like eco friendly could just be a
synonym for cheap this serves as an
intriguing reminder that for their
unprecedented scale the original Star
Wars trilogy was completely and afraid
to employ guerrilla filmmaking
techniques in service of ass galaxy
spanning vision that's pretty rad if you
ask us on another wholesome notes when
you think about it it's actually a
testament to the skill of the filmmakers
that the enormous worldwide audience for
The Empire Strikes Back was so utterly
sucked into its world that every last
one of them failed to catch this glaring
detail for so long check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about star wars are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and at the Bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]